i am opening the committee of conference
on house bill 1460
this is the off-label
relative to the off-label use of
prescription drugs and relative to
pharmacy prescriptions
in the senate um there was work done to
make sure that there is a little bit
more understanding of what's going on
there the language included a form
created by the board of medicine or the
board of nursing
to be approved
there's a question about how much time
and effort that would take for the board
of medicine and also making sure that we
are referencing other uses of off-label
medicine so we have a proposed amendment
that um takes most of the words that we
had already
approved in both of the committees and
adds a little bit more detail to flesh
it out
and
and get more to the point and provide
more protection
so the way that it would read would be
the state of new hampshire confirms that
strong support for shared decision
making between health care professionals
and their patients a licensee may
lawfully prescribe an fda approved drug
product for an off-label
indication and to be held at the same
standard of care as when prescribing for
an online label indication with a
off-label use of the drug product for
this indication as long-standing common
use this is really important because 70
of prescriptions i've seen a number as
high as 70 of prescriptions are off
label and this protects the routine
practice where the doctor may not even
know that there's an improve that
whether or not that indication has been
approved for that drug
so when that's the case keep practicing
as you do
b is when there is medical evidence to
support this use and no known evidence
contraindicating such use including but
not limited to peer-reviewed studies and
practice guidelines from relevant
medical societies
we had had the word sound scientific
evidence a sound scientific medical
evidence
and the question was raised by several
people who determines what sound
peer-reviewed publications and medical
society guidelines are sound so if we
can point to those and there's no no
concerns that would be widely known
about that indication and that drug
it should be routine use as well that
doesn't need any particular
documentation
now we move to that area where it hasn't
been adopted by societies or there's not
a large body of evidence in the
peer-reviewed papers
this is that area where we may have one
like our colleague from walpole who was
able to have her husband benefit from
innovative therapeutics for his cancer
where he was one of the first people
treated there was no body of evidence at
that point there was no data there was a
hope that it might help him and it did
and we want to make sure that people
here in new hampshire are able to
benefit from that so long as they and
their doctor know what is going on
so that brings us to those core
principles of informed consent that are
laid out in the american medical
association
their medical code of ethics
opinion on informed consent which
requires that you present relevant
information accurately accurately and
sensitively in keeping with the
patient's preferences for receiving
medical information the position should
include information about the burdens
risks and its expected benefits of all
options including foregoing treatment
we're fortunate to have a pharmacist on
this committee of conference with us and
there's been some improvements made
since uh this was drafted at ols
thanks to representative merchant
he's
recognized that we need to have a form
that can be faxed to the pharmacist so
the pharmacist knows that this informed
consent has happened
this would be changing section c
to read
the licensee has provided and the
patient or the if the patient is a minor
the patient's parent or guardian has
signed an informed consent form that
includes
the known potential benefits known
potential risks alternative treatment
options expected prognosis without
treatment and a disclosure that the
prescription is for an off-label
indication
the signed informed consent form shall
remain a part of the patient's medical
record
i think with that and with these changes
we have a pretty comprehensive look and
i'd like to look to senator sherman for
his input
yes thank you madam chair this has
uh i talked to the board of medicine
today and uh we also reached lindsay
courtney to just confirm that
they're okay with this and i spoke
with them directly and they are fine
with it it really does capture
their concerns
about the bill that were there before i
just wanted to make sure that we are
recognizing that
c will be modified at the three spots
not just the one dealing with physicians
but it will be modified lines 13 through
lines 28 through 31
[Music]
and then yes
lines eleven
through fourteen on page two correct yes
that's correct unfortunately it's the
same language all the time yeah i just
wanna make sure that we're not just
amending that one section
so that's all i'm support
um
can we read again
representative merchant's language
because i think the way it's written
here it doesn't include everything that
you said
and do it slowly so that
my penmanship can keep up with you
uh thank you that's why i opened us just
a few moments later uh then we had it
would read the licensee has provided and
the patient
or if the patient is a minor
yup got it the patient's parent or
guardian
that's why i went to another piece of
paper it's a lot of words
here
has signed an informed consent form
yep
that includes yeah
and that goes to the language there the
known potential benefits okay and then
the rest is what was on representative
merchant's amendment to the amendment
all right
i want to read this again out loud
the licensee has provided
and the patient
or if the patient is a
minor and the patient's parent or
guardian has signed an informed consent
form
that includes the known potential
benefits known potential risks
alternative treatment options expected
prognosis without treatment and the
disclosure that the prescription is for
an off-label indication
then the addition of the sentence the
signed informed consent form
shall remain part of the medical record
of the patient's medical record that's
the pt there yes she'll remain part of
the
patients that wasn't in there either
it's right there it's that pt oh yeah
yeah you doctors and pharmacists you're
it's written for an artist
okay
all right okay
um
can i ask one question
john
good to go with this
from the department
leon if i could respond to senator
bradley's question for the record john
williams director of legislative affairs
the department is fine with this we did
recognize that the primary principal
agencies involved was the office of
professional licensure and certification
and the board of medicine and we we
appreciate the um earnest effort made by
the uh conferee chair for the house to
reaching out to various parties and we
are fine thank you okay thank you
paula you're good to go
you've talked to lindsay
and the board of medicine all right i'd
move that to senator seed to the
amendment
um normally i would say
that we should come back
and review this
um i don't think it's necessary in this
case um so the sooner it gets done
in case there's there's a lot of moving
parts here in my penmanship it should
all be good
i don't think we need to come back
thank you we'll make sure that we have
this language if we have anything we
have the tape and we'll make sure that
this is done quickly so that we can all
sign off and if there's a problem fix
that
thank you what does the house agree to
the this amendment
yes
yes yes
then if the senate agrees then we have
this amendment it'll be drafted and we
can sign off and i will close the
committee of conference for house bill
1466.
i call the committee of conference on
house bill 1487 to order
this is
this is relative to procedure for
withdrawal from the vaccine registry
this bill allows
a notarized form to be used instead of
going to the healthcare provider in
order to withdraw from the vaccine
registry the senate had been concerned
about the differentiation between
parents and children and actually came
up with some beautiful language that
addresses the
challenges that we're facing
in the current health care shortage
the senate said
that the form shall require the
signature of a health care provider
and i think that we believe that that's
something that should apply both to
children and adults
and that children adults should also be
able to have a notarized form signed by
either the patient or the patient's
parent and guardian if they are a minor
of course there are some consequences to
taking responsibility for your own data
and your own health
which is what anybody who is choosing to
withdraw from the registry does
if you withdraw from the registry and
you show up in the emergency room
they're not just going to be able to
call up your vaccination record and say
that you've been immunized against
measles or that you've been immunized
against covid and so you may be treated
in such a way as somebody who hasn't
been immunized and they'll be they'll be
different
different diagnostic workups that you go
through and you might be in a bubble
room as well
we have an amendment that
allows a form to be notarized
notarized or by a healthcare provider
which means that you don't need to be
your healthcare provider which is great
in this day and age when too many are
retiring
or
other changes in practice mean that
you're no longer with your existing
healthcare provider
we also have some language that
addresses some concerns from the
department
the forum is created by the department
and that's done in the rules process
so if when we add the language the form
provided by the department shall include
information and consequences that the
responsibility to maintain vaccination
records becomes the responsibility of
the patient or the patient's parent or
guardian if a minor
we give them that ability to put that
information in that form
i think we all believe that that's very
important because when you take
responsibility you need to understand
what that responsibility is just like
some of our parents may have had a
vaccination card when we were enrolling
in school and they had to show that
every time you went to camp if you
choose not to be in the registry that's
probably what things are going to look
like for you but if you don't want to be
in the registry that's a burden you're
willing to bear
so i i guess we'll see if there's any
questions here and then we can have the
department uh share specifically what
consequences they think that people need
to be aware of as well
representative leon uh
so you're offering amendment 2028
yes i am thank you yeah and uh with the
amen and you amended that with some ex
further language yes
and that's what we're looking at right
now yes we are looking at amendment 2028
h which is a draft committee of
conference amendment and then additional
language that's been distributed here in
the room
thank you for that thank you
and uh uh
if i may john you you're we're all set
yeah all right
so
let me just listen
representative merchant thank you madam
chair
in regards to the language if you look
at house bill 1487 the one created by
the
um
researcher the clerk
right now i would pose a slight
modification to it to read the forum
provided by the department shall include
information and consequences of
withdrawing from the registry and that
the responsibility to maintain vaccine
vaccination records become the
responsibility of the patient or the
patient's parent or guardian of the
minor
i i think that's much clearer and it
defines what consequences are
which was my problem
thank you
thank you does anybody need to hear
anything else or are you ready to agree
as the house does the house agree to
this language
yes yes
you agree
okay the house agrees with this language
microphone please so i can hear
please tell me what to do these days
uh we the senator seeds to the house
with the changes
thank you then would it be correct for
me to close this committee
then i close this committee of
conference thank you all very much
you